deux choses d'abord y avait déjà eu ce
baiser scandaleux sexiste du prince
charles
y est maintenant on nous sort c'est on
nous ressort ça secoue surnom qui n'ont
rien demandé à personne qu'on met une
chaumière j'ai une grosse envie c'est de
la discrimination à la haine de
l'humiliation pour les mains dans les
mains blanches s est arrêté avec
blanche-neige
sexistes contre les est en train de tout
gâcher blanche-neige 4 du fener blanche
passée blanche skoda
pour supprimant blanche mais achiri les
cadors c'est comme de tels films et
préféré mais là la saint suaire tamayo
je ne dis pas que je défends tu es et
qu'on demande jamais leur avis aux leur
avis aux intéressés mais tu crois
vraiment que j'allais appeler grincheuse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
battante elle attend on va plus
gg je le green it gets le green bay je
suis
un jeune tu captes de malte et dans la
mine
[Rires]
sans déconner là mais c'est vrai alors
oui ya un an car aller un pur instant
climatique
aux médias américains déjà c'est lui le
débat alors là pour le coup j'étais
bourg mais
concrètement contre et déjà y avait des
nains qui avait des parts dans des
petites tailles qu'avait débat nous on
bosse nous on a envie demander notre
avis hélas avant systématiquement de
sectoriser voilà non mais le lancer
n'invente daudignon dit à l'oreille on
dit d'accord et alors et 10 ha il ya
kelly vélo midi qui vous dit agile déjà
qu'on ne dit pas non dix personnes de
petite taille et
et voilà la raison est pressé parce qu
on a lancé le débat sur les noms sa
petite taille
tu vas tu as pu blanche jack est cette
personne
sept petits
benjamins qui est sortie de one way
sinon gillet cette petite parcelle
[Musique]
beinheim
un conte pour enfants c'est justement
censé faire peur aux enfants raconter
une
société en l'occurrence à ce moment là
on voudront cela voudrait dire que
toutes les belles mères sont des
marathons qui veulent en pointe dans
cette fille ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait tout justement le ritz n'est
pas de transposer est là c'est qu'il
s'agit pas de représenter les personnes
de petite taille par les sept nains à
tuer c'est vrai que dans la vie des
personnes qui dans les mares de vote
bien pensante
la vie renforce et toi t'es pas médaille
des nations bien
conscience et gilles verdez et dans les
champs il faut dire personnes de petite
taille il aura aussi vient de m'envoyer
à 10 personnes de petite taille
parce qu'ensuite je vous jure qu'il
aurait il ya une personne qui a une
association pour la défense des
personnes de petite taille c'est
monsieur petits gens et après c'est vrai
qu'il est très sympa et à chaque fois il
à ceci près que non c'est pas une n'est
pas une insulte sur nos dictionnaires
aînés par c'est pas une insulte en sur
pato me tue de taille mais c'est pas une
invention dix personnes de petite taille
mais on parle du manque un son si ce nom
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et là c'est bon là vraiment des géniaux
vraiment là c'est non mais ça y est
c'est vraiment vraiment des génies causé
je vais pas faire ce test de qi
j'ai papeete a pas sanitaires là je la
passe alors de là dans le cerveau on
l'achète pas ce qu'ils ont ils ont été
réécrits
alors guillaume genton aussi le rôle que
j'adore et en plus les toucs je préfère
eh ben dis donc ils sont redoute même
étude il veut aller x est censé raconter
la société la scène raconte rien à part
véhiculer des clichés en soit les
personnes de petite taille lequel ils
sont balle assez représentés comme des
nains de jardin vivant et y croit tous
les noms mais désolé mais les dessins
animés ils ont un rôle éducatif auprès
de désir d'enfant tous les regards sont
coquets qui fait un peu je pense que
grandir et être éduqué en regardant ça
ça peut engendrer des néophytes les
personnes de petite c'est le paradigme
et 10 rebonds au contraire parce que
justement on voit des personnages
présentés en c1 clusif et donc du coup l
asepex lorsqu'on les voit l'inversé le
paradigme ben oui comme ça aboutit du
paradigme
valérie a raison franchement la cancel
culture ça lobotomise les esprits toi et
gym c'est juste n'importe quoi parce que
les stéréotypes voulait les effacer mais
en fait si on efface les sérotypes
écrivain raté la cible
[Applaudissements]
ça n'est pas du tout raté l'écrivaine
réussi il ya quand même des cas parler
il faut que ça existe c'est important
alors de la même manière tu vas me dire
s'il avait été noir en fait on est
encore plus choquant pour gmail aurait
trouvé ça et méchant pour les nains et
personnes de petite taille et méchant
pour les noirs en fait il faut arrêter
vous êtes juste malade c'est votre
esprit tordu qui fait le lien
différence entre être inclusif et faire
des stéréotypes mais sa diversité et
janet jackson
quand j'étais petit et je vais mépriser
les gens de petite taille va bien ça va
influencer vos clichés les enfants qui
regardent
vous êtes en train de flinguer la
société comme gilles verdez et john ont
surtout toi j ouer tu en train de
flinguer la chanson moi je te le dis
depuis un an mais non mais vraiment et
on t'aime beaucoup mais tu en train de
saluer la société fait les gens comme
toi qui sont en train aujourd'hui après
deux faits reconnaît dans une société où
on se fait chier d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'a dit michel sardou ce matin oui
assurera-t-elle ses preuves et c'est
pour ça que des gens comme les chasseurs
nous disent qu'ils supportent plus la
société c'est à cause de gens comme toi
oui j'adorerais java ou c
est ce qu on fait le lien par exemple
quand on parlait hier de soprano qu'il
est quel est l'esprit tordu qui fait le
lien entre un singe et un noir mail tous
les clichés
il ya un documentaire emmène là dessus
sur les personnes qui se moquent de
leurs représentants vous avec des
bananes et des esprits
j'ai gardé savaient ce qu'ils sont même
en train de faire c'est que comme c'est
du passé ils vont transformer parce que
c'est un remake ils vont transformer
blanche neige avec une actrice latino et
il espère que du combat oublier la
polémique sur un vélo et nous et nous
ont dit et nous et mes amis on dit ça ne
passera pas
qui aime bien les saisies de connaître
les mains mais non ça ne passera jamais
pas soutient je suis tout seul la
jeunesse de l'histoire c'est juste et
non y avoir justement parce que écrit
l'histoire latino pour interpréter blanc
écrit l'histoire le comédien qui joue
dans game of thrones dont le nom
m'échappe a dit et pourtant voilà il
faudrait revoir l'histoire
après le souper a pris moi je suis pas
du tout d'accord parce que je trouve que
c'est transformer les mythes les comptes
comme ça qui sont hyper mythique que je
comprends pas trop justement de la
bienséance séchage est insupportable et
valls une polémique supprimer plus de 20
dans les jardins dans les pavillons
dresse toute la journée sans rien faire
ça aussi j'en veux plus voir
les pauvres ils sont toute la journée
dans les jardins les flux de magie
je vais ensuite polémique va changer ce
système où ils vont fêter leurs 30 ans
la disney vous allez voir les gens ils
vont être au taquet sur la blouse
blanche malheureux mais c'est racialiste
associé gilles à ce moment là bas bien
sûr mais sachez que disney c'est quand
même pas choquant voyez je me rappelle
quand j'étais petit en 1920
je regardais bombi quand la maman à la
normale
marc était traumatisée
la maman de bambi est mort
j'étais bien
[Rires]
non vous savez ça veut dire que si on
doit changer tout disney une culture
disney c'est compliqué c'est mignon
c'était pour les enfants sèchent on
va on va demander à bomber centenaire
mais c'est surtout que là l'image des
nara les nains sont gentils sont
positifs ya rien de méchant vous savez
que pendant toute une période bernard
qui est très vieux doit s'en souvenir il
ya bien un qui s'appelle gayral
quéral c'était un acteur est il joué que
dans les rôles de méchant dans les
traits de cape et d'épée là on peut on
peut se dire alors on associer identité
selena et les méchants l'allumage est
positive ils sont adorables tout le
monde mais à nous de tout gagner avec la
dans un film de cape et d'épée au
cabinet gartner
aussi le nak
journal elle a prédit
jean méo et on a ici on n'est pas chez
vos mères
vraiment pas chez nous mais on aime
passionnel non noté passionnés des
passionnés sur une question aux preneurs
mais qu'est-ce qui veut diriger la
question producteurs il paraît qu'il y
de nombreuses plaintes contre fort
boyard pour qu'on retire passe-partout
est ce que c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors je vais vous dire mais moi je suis
pas producteur fort boyard bonjour je
laisse bien que djelloul non je suis je
suis fait partie du groupe mais il ya eu
de nombreuses plaintes à la concernant
fort boyard ce que le fort était trop
loin
non non non c'est pas vrai nom
maintenant pour l'instant ça va ces
instances à tirage
passe montagne passe moi le sel toute
façon
même pas final qui va regarder des
prochains
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
salutaire donc il doit arriver dans fort
boyard